hi guys sci-fi recapped here today I am
going to explain the film called The
Hunt spoilers ahead watch out and stay
safe the movie begins with a woman named
Athena texting her friends in a group
chat while everyone is sharing memes and
laughing Athena sends a strange text
about how excited she is regarding the
hunt in the Mansion the scene then
shifts to a plane where a stewardess is
asking a man if he wants a snack when
she tells him the available menu the
snobby man mentions that he would like
to have something different that can
only be made in a kitchen being a little
hesitant the stewardess asks him if he
would like to have champagne to which he
finally agrees following this a
stumbling man appears startling everyone
when the snobbish man from earlier
notices him he comments that one of them
is awake similarly the old man next to
the snobby man gets up from his seat and
tries to calm down The Stumbling man
after successfully convincing the man to
lie down the old man requests the
stewardess pen then shockingly he stabs
the man with the pen causing blood to
burst from his neck however The
Stumbling man is still alive so he
attacks the old man with the bottle of
champagne and then flings the bottle
around on the other side the noise
awakens Athena who approaches The
Stumbling man from behind and pokes him
in the eye with her heels the snobbish
champagne guy freaks out and yells that
it hasn't even begun yet in response
Athena tells him that there is no
emotion in war as she removes The
Stumbling man's eyeball from her heels
then they drag the man's body to a
compartment where we see a blonde girl
lying next to him in the next scene the
blonde girl from earlier wakes up in an
unknown location with a gag hooked in
her mouth after failing to get rid of
the gag she stands up and sees another
girl with a gag across the river the
blonde girl tries to talk with her but
the latter ignores her and walks away in
the meantime she notices a man and
follows him to a large green field with
a crate in the middle there she also
notices a bunch of other people
approaching the area with gags in their
mouths similar to hers one of them
approaches the crate and attempts to
open it despite a man warning him that
it could be a trap however the man
ignores the the latter's warning and
continues to open it while the others
hide to everyone's surprise a pig steps
out the man then pulls out a rack full
of various weapons while everyone else
rushes toward the crate to get their
hands on the weapon the blonde girl
discovers the key to the gags then they
begin Distributing weapons among
themselves until they are attacked by
sudden gunfire all of them try to run
and hide in order to save themselves but
it doesn't work the blonde girl
eventually gets shot in the head and
another man dies while attempting to
shoot in the direction of the bullets
similarly a girl runs from the crate
only to fall in a ditch when one of the
guys notices this he goes to help her
but finds her pierced with huge Nails he
still pulls her up and they try to
escape but unfortunately they step on a
landmine and explode into pieces on the
other hand a guy finds himself in front
of a fence after running from the
gunshot area he soon senses someone
behind him so he points his gun at him
however it is the man who opened the
crate earlier likewise two more people
appear there and they all begin climbing
the fence while doing so the crate man
gets struck by an arrow he tries to
escape but gets struck by more arrows
and eventually dies meanwhile the other
three reach a gas station when they
enter they find an elderly couple who
are terrified by their entrance with
guns they look scared and subsequently
inform them that they are in the state
of Arkansas the man from the fence
earlier then funds the police who assure
them that they will locate them and save
them soon however one of the three
suddenly starts choking after eating a
poison donut when they turn their heads
to face the couple they are already
wearing gas masks and throwing a smoke
grenade at them the fence guy tries to
attack them but the old man shoots him
down similarly they murder the second
guy by choking him with the grenade
after successfully killing all three
they begin cleaning the scene to make it
appear as if nothing had happened while
doing so the elderly lady notices the
fence guy's wedding ring which takes her
by surprise her husband tells her not to
worry because the man they killed is a
monster and a racist they quickly start
arguing over racism until they get a
radio call a woman from the radio then
alerts them that another person is
approaching there hence the couple
begins to prepare their act Crystal the
girl from the river before arrives a few
seconds later and is warmly welcomed by
the old couple she requests for
cigarettes and asks them where she is as
the old woman hands her the cigarette
and the change she mentions that they
are in Arkansas after looking at the
change Crystal suddenly attacks the
couple then she reveals that the
cigarette price is too low for Arkansas
after doing so she snatches the gun from
the counter and shoots both of them dead
following this she exits the store and
notices a truck in front of her when she
inspects the truck outside she discovers
a Croatian license plate covered beneath
a false Arkansas plate in addition she
discovers a booby trap link to a bomb
wired to the driver's door she then
hides behind the bushes while listening
to the radio since they were unable to
connect with the old couple the people
from the radio soon send a drone to
check the situation however the Drone is
shot down by Gary another captive like
Crystal when Gary starts approaching the
truck Crystal warns him about the Trap
she also tells him that he basically
informed the people about their presence
by destroying the Drone after this she
starts walking towards the railway
tracks she noticed earlier and Gary
quickly follows after her as they are
walking along the tracks Gary tells her
his theory about their current situation
he mentions about the article in which a
group of liberal globalist deletes
kidnap Ordinary People and bring them to
a manner where they hunt them down like
animals however Crystal doesn't take his
theory seriously in the meantime she
hears the sound of a train nearby and
they both start running to catch up with
it when they successfully board the
train they come across a bunch of
non-english-speaking immigrants whom
Gary suspects to be crisis actors the
train soon gets raided by Croatian
soldiers so all of them including the
immigrants surrender Gary then tries to
convince the soldiers that he and
Crystal are Americans and that the
immigrants are crisis actors however the
soldiers do not believe him following
this one of the Immigrant guys
approaches Gary and informs him that he
is the sole actor present he informs
Gary that the raid is real and that he
should cooperate with him Gary on the
other hand does not listen to him and
instead places a grenade inside the
guy's pants which eventually blows him
up after this crystal is taken to a
refugee camp where she meets officers
who speak English she instructs them to
contact the American Embassy however
they instead bring Dawn another escaped
captive while Don is telling her the
same theories as Gary an officer from
the U.S embassy arrives to take them on
the way there the official questions
Crystal and Dawn about why they were
chosen for the hunt which makes her
suspicious of him as a result she throws
the official out of the car and drives
him over killing him Dawn is taken aback
by this and begins to question Crystal's
actions however he soon shuts up when
they discover Gary's body in the trunk
along with a box labeled bride money and
a map revealing that he was on the side
of the bad guys next off Don insists on
leaving in the car but Crystal refuses
she then tells him the brutal story of
the jackrabbit and the box turtle a
version of The Tortoise and the hair in
which the jackrabbit it later kills the
box turtle along with his family after
losing back in the location where
Crystal and the other prisoners were
first discovered we witnessed the
champagne guy and the rest of them
having stupid talks and conflicts later
the champagne guy goes outside to potty
where Don distracts him with the Peg and
Crystal eventually kills him with a
knife because of the noise from outside
the others grow alarmed being all
nervous they shoot down the pig that Don
dropped inside moments later Crystal
appears and kills one of the men she
then starts attacking the others she
shoots the soldier first then stabs the
woman with a knife similarly she has a
dramatic encounter with another man in
which they both fight for a rifle but
Crystal eventually shoots him down she
then murders the man who had escaped
earlier as she's about to walk away
thinking she has got everyone the
soldier suddenly attacks her however the
resilient Crystal overpowers him and
brutally hits him with a pipe after a
while Crystal points her gun at the
woman she stabbed before but right then
Don appears out of nowhere she asks Don
to question the woman about why they
were hunting for Crystal and the others
to which the woman gives a foolish
idealistic argument this makes Crystal
want to kill her but Don stops her
saying she is a woman when Crystal hears
this she asks the woman if she should be
spared because of her gender and she
says no as a result Crystal shoots her
following this Athena suddenly calls out
to Don through the radio asking if he
killed Crystal Dawn pleads with Crystal
not to trust Athena while Crystal tells
him to put down his gun since Dawn
refuses to disarm Crystal shoots him she
then assaults and kills the wounded
soldier after finding Athena's location
in the next scene we see a flashback
which reveals that Athena's group text
about the hunt was actually a joke
however when it was released on the
internet it gained a lot of attention
from people as a result of the internet
outrage the participants of the group
lost their jobs later they decided to
make the joke come true so they kidnap
the people who shared and created
internet materials about the hunt in the
process of choosing the people for the
hunt Athena got personally outraged by a
social media post Crystal head made
about her so she insisted on including
her coming back to the present Crystal
wearily walks around Athena's house
until she notices her cooking something
here Athena reveals that the crystal who
shared the horrible post is actually
another person this means that she
mistakenly bought the wrong person
hearing this Crystal becomes angry and
the two get into a fierce fight she
begins throwing several items at Athena
but the latter Dodges them impressively
the fight then moves outside where
Athena stabs Crystal with a vegetable
cutter despite this our main character
pulls Athena in eventually impaling her
by the other side of the cutter Hayden
and dies but Crystal survives with the
fight finally being over she gets up
eats the bread and then Burns her wound
with a blowtouch to avoid infection in
the final scene crystal dresses in
Athena's clothes takes her dog and
Boards her plane where she enjoys
champagne and food with the stewardess
subscribe and hit that like button to
help our Channel grow turn the
notifications on so you won't miss any
of our new videos thanks for watching